hey what's up guys my name is a general
welcome to episode 58 of game
programming so today we're going to take
a look at a few more sprites that we
need to actually um make our game to
finish up them the map because remember
this portion of the series we're
basically just gonna take a look at
making maps and then getting that down
alright so what one thing I did that I
actually didn't show on camera I guess
is I actually fixed up the Turner the
King churners right
so Andy wall the guy made the original
sprites and you know the sprite to me
because the first one wasn't didn't look
nice when for the side walking on it
animations I mean so yeah if he set up
and now it's now it's good so I just
basically change his price but um the
other thing is we need to make some more
tiles because currently if we go into
tiles or tile rather into our tile class
you'll see that we've got like what
forget three tiles could remember void
tile is just like just in case tiles not
earlier we're not really gonna use it
but um we've got yeah we've got three
tiles here and we need a lot more than
that to make a nice looking game so I'll
ask you guys if you wanted to send in
your sprite sheets and basically off
textures that you've actually made and
then you know let me use them for series
and I got a lot of textures from you
guys but I think the most comprehensive
and the most complete and the most
pretty looking textures war were by
Jakob Blomquist Blomqvist I have him
from pronouncing that right but um Blanc
worsted or Blom Blomqvist adore he sent
these estrogen so they look really nice
and he's already made them himself so
I'm gonna have to try some on that but
yeah so we got some nice like water or
even ice whatever bunch of walls which
is what I like as well as like watch
different grass textures which is
awesome and you know different stone and
silver on it which is nice I really like
this texture pack this this it makes
this grass completely terrible some
people yeah get rid of that grass but
we're definitely gonna put in these
textures into our Spri chain now and use
them so over here so this is like the
king Jonas rather die replaced but
I've just opened up his stuff here as
well and I'm just gonna copy and paste
it into my spreadsheet and we're gonna
use that so let's just grab all this oh
that's even transparent that's very cool
it wasn't only transparent but it's
lower opacity I guess so we're going to
put this probably right over here
I might actually make several sprite
shades in the future but first I just
want to get this down so we can
definitely get rid of let's just cut
this I guess and like paste in here
because we don't need that grass texture
and fix this up there yeah all right
awesome so the first thing I want to do
is probably start using this grass
session set in fact all that we really
need to do here is if we just want to
try out it like in a different sprite
for grass or we need to do is really
just change the coordinates a phoner go
from this grass so let's just say this
one which looks like it's 0 1 2 3 4 5 0
1 2 3 4 summer 4 so I'm working on very
little sleep much like went to bed like
4:30 a.m. last night because I was at a
party so um yeah so yeah but that's
really a cat stuffing on it go save that
there we go so yeah it was kind of nice
let's try a different one um just try
one more
you really play around that use if the
rocks kind of looking in certain but
that's fine
it loves nice I like that I like the
view of that so yeah I might get some
one I think I saw some rocks that you
guys sent it as well so I might do that
later I don't know if you guys want to
seal this graphics work on like on
screen in the series if you do let me
know in a comment below if you don't
want to see all this graphic stuff and
you just want to only see code basically
and you don't really want to see the
level the levels or the or the textures
I guess get designed and implemented
drop a comment let me know what you guys
think about that but um I don't know I
think it'd be awesome having um you know
the entire game I guess being made in
front of you guys instead of me best
living like oh yeah I've compiled
several sprite shades now and they wrote
if you go but um yeah that's just my
opinion so let me know what you got fur
but yeah I guess now that we've got that
covered
we're gonna make a bunch of watch tiles
so whoo basically the way that I
approach this is I am a very organised
young man at least I try to be and I
especially try to be in in my
programming there's some it's something
about organization and keeping code
groups and clean really appeals to me
which is why this is like the hierarchy
of our thing here which is why I really
like to actually keep everything
separate and everything fully organized
because I don't know it's just it's just
cool it's just cool like that
so in textures I'm gonna make probably a
folder called levels and I'll blow in
there in a minute and I guess in levels
though would probably have might make it
I might make another one called shades
this will be like sprite shades yeah ok
cool
I'll tell Finn to that so I'll put
sprite shade into there and level into
levels all right that's good good and
obviously just before our game crashes
for no apparent reason we need to
quickly fix the folder structure so this
obviously becomes in levels right so
I've just moved it and the actual sprite
sheet I think
was in here so levels spreadsheet
awesome the check that runs not okay so
we forgot to replace one thing I'm not
sure it is though actually we could
probably just debug it that'd be easier
so it looks like it's the load for the
spritesheet no no that should be where's
path okay now that should worked Oh
level sorry my bad
sheets not levels terminate try that
again awesome cool sorry yeah so we'll
call this one I guess see I want I might
I kind of want to separate tiles per
levels so in other words spawn level
what do we want to ask born level to
look like that's really interesting
there's actually a pretty high
resolution aren't there is really 16 by
16 yeah
huh almost looks like 32 by 32 they look
really nice though so yeah but anyway I
guess what we want to do let's just
close that I guess what we want to do is
split it up sort of so I might make a
new sheet and the spawn level let's just
take a look at what this one levels
gonna have it's definitely gonna have
some grass it's gonna have some walls
gonna have water that's like three maybe
five ish maybe about six textures for
the level for that so successors mains
basically if we have three by three I
might make a room for nine textures
actually should we do that
yeah oops my girlfriend mine that
textures
so again effect I don't actually have
the grid plug-in on this computer yet so
I just literally copy and paste
themselves oh okay
whoops so we'll have nine textures and I
I will simply grab the textures that I
want from the spreadsheet and I guess
definitely all edit them out later but
let's just say we want to use this grass
I love have those different grass
textures that's awesome this grass we
might maybe even this is almost look
like a hedge kind of like that I'll pop
that in as well
definitely use water I'll show how I
feel about transparent water but I guess
it's kind of cool right I'll put that
there as four walls definitely gonna use
these so I'll pop them here and I don't
know I mean you know I ain't cracked
ground no I think that's pretty good
actually if there was a floor that
almost looks like a floor but I'm not a
big fan of that
mm-hm I might even use I'm gonna use
cracks Lord we want like a cracked floor
or do we want like a I'm just gonna make
a floor out of this I think like a
wouldn't rule out of this so this will
be like our floor let's just edit that
real quick at the moment that kind of
bricks but um we can change that pretty
easily so basically what I want to do is
sort of scale it up a lot so let's just
try and edit this I scale it up
pixilated I just get the aspect ratio
down I scale it up a bit like that and
then it will copy some more squares and
just replace that I almost feel like my
atlast yeah then I guess we could sort
of make like a floorboard type look if I
just sort of do this you'll see what I'm
sort of getting up pretty soon and I
like this color as well so I just
sorry yaar just a simple basic sort of
full bullet at Yale what's that look
like
that's kinda nice actually I like that
there we go so that's like a
nice-looking floor I guess save that
okay so we'll save it in sheets
obviously and we'll save it we'll call
this like a spawn level or something
spawn level tiles I guess and that'll
just contain a details for our spawn
level so if we go over here and the I
guess these episodes gonna be kind of
long on there but um if we go over here
into our sprites a class which is why
we're in which is awesome so we're gonna
plug static sprite sheet and we'll call
this one a spawn level and let's see so
it'll be equal to new sprite sheet and
we'll just go textures sheets to on
level dot PNG and the size of it right
the size is well it's 48 so that's it
just like that awesome so now we'll go
into tile Java and I'll actually sorry
sprite Java which is nice open right
here and we'll just I guess we're
looking all the flower I almost want to
like sort of grab this but obviously we
can't do that
but it would still be pretty cool for
the group like that but we can't cuz
they're static but let's just over here
we'll put like the spawn level sprites
here all right so spawn level sprites
here and I guess we'll make a player
surprise here
awesome that's not gonna I say just like
I like it just do where I like it so
let's public static sprite so they'll
have like the spawn prefix so spawn
grass equals new sprite and remember
that's zero zero as well but the again
the difference here and the sizes 6-10
the difference here is that it's going
to be sprite shaped dot
instead of being spreadsheet dovetails
it's gonna be spreadsheet at one level
so that's very important you don't
forget that so we've got we've basically
used up six textures here so I'm just
gonna copy that a few times and we'll go
so spawn grass what else do we have
looks like a hedge so I'm just gonna
call it a hedge then we've got water
then we've got wall one wall too and
floor all right and I guess we'll just
quickly change hedge to do that's one
across that's two across that's one and
then the rest I don't actually one of
them stood down I think that's cool so I
think that right yeah that's right okay
awesome
so now we've got a bunch of these kind
of sprites we're also going to go into
tile dot Java and this is where I'd also
like to be hoping I show and tile we've
got a bunch of tiles because tiles will
be specific to different things we can
right click hit new folder and I'm just
gonna make a new folder called spawn
level right
and then in here we're gonna have all of
our different classes such as for
example the cities are all tile plus
obviously but the spawn levels gonna
have a tower called cross tile for
example but just in case we'll probably
want to call it spawn spawn grass tile
right and again that's going to extend
tile and tile wife to be important to
imported from the other thing and
obviously is going to have to inherit a
constructor as usual and it's also going
to render each I'll thing this is gonna
be a freaking long long episode as well
as in it but if we go to like the grass
tile we can just copy and paste that and
I should really move that render method
up the hierarchy but I might do that
next episodes I think so that'll be the
spawn grass
and we're gonna finish all the other
ones in the next episode again
programming so I hope you liked this
video guys let me know if you guys want
to see like the graphical work and all
that stuff done in the videos and I'll
see you guys next time
later
you